and finally new rule someone has to tell
china you can steal our trade secrets
our software and our intellectual
property but we draw the line at our hot
freestyle skiers
now
if you've been like me over the past few
weeks glued to your tv watching the
olympics that makes exactly two of us
we knew they were [ __ ] countries but
who knew there was a [ __ ] superpower
but
i'm sure you've heard about american
citizen eileen goo the beautiful model
influencer and now gold medal winning
skier who was born and raised here in
america but who chose to ski in the
olympics for china cool huh
is it is that cool now
choose to represent a totalitarian
police state over america
the olympics pretends to only be about
sports but of course the games have
always been a bit of a proxy war for
which country has the best system and by
choosing team china aileen gu became a
living symbol of china's triumph over
the west which wouldn't bother me so
much if i thought china had triumphed
over us in the ways that really matter
but they haven't
now we do have human rights issues right
here at home we do
but we're still at least for another
three years
a democracy based on freedom and they
are an authoritarian surveillance state
based on how'd you like to disappear for
a few months
like that tennis player who recently
vanished for a while when she said she'd
been raped by a government official
we do still throw too many black people
in jail but perspective matters china
has basically jailed an entire ethnic
minority
the uyghurs a situation that both the
trump and biden administrations has
called a genocide america is not close
to that
and it's a cynical dodge to pretend that
china's sins should be overlooked
because we all do it
no
in 1997 britain returned hong kong to
china with an agreement that beijing
that from beijing that hong kong could
retain its free press honest courts and
democratic government
well they lied
democracy and freedom are being crushed
there and china doesn't want anyone to
talk about it and because so much money
is involved no one does two years ago
when the general manager of the houston
rockets daryl mori tweeted fight for
freedom stand with hong kong he
was forced to apologize
in america we're supposed to root for
democratic government not apologize for
it
but the nba has a television deal with
china worth a billion and a half dollars
so
lebron james said maury needed to be
educated on the situation
the situation being i got some shoes to
sell
[Applause]
is a chinese word but boy americans have
gotten good at it
for years google proudly refused to
kowtow to chinese censors adopting the
slogan don't be evil but the chinese
market proves so lucrative that well
okay a little evil
that's the deal china offers american
companies and celebrities we'll give you
access to our billion plus consumers as
long as you shut up about the whole
police state genocide thing
john cena took that deal well come on
china accounts for 34 of global box
office and he's a movie star now so
like the uyghurs
last year he learned he needed to get
some re-education
[Applause]
you see
he john referred to taiwan as a country
as if it was a separate country from
china which it is
what china would like to do to taiwan
what it did to tibet and what it's now
doing to hong kong
so we were treated to this video
well
and i thought steroids shrunk your balls
wowie when a country can make your big
muscly macho man action stars grovel in
their language you know you're
somebody's [ __ ]
in the original top gun tom cruise wore
a bomber jacket with the flags of
several asian countries that are our
allies sewn on the back
well the flag for taiwan has now
magically disappeared for the upcoming
top gun maverick well he used to be a
maverick now he does whatever china says
so
so can you really blame 18 year old
eileen goo who's already made over 31
million dollars as the face of 23 brand
products in china for following in the
footsteps of other american celebrities
some of goo's defenders say it's racist
to ask if she's still an american
citizen and she herself won't say
why is that racist
why was it racist to think that kovit
might have originated from a lab league
as opposed to from eating bats besides
the fact that the idea that covet came
from eating gross weird food seems way
more racist than the idea that it came
from a high-tech lab
[Applause]
besides that the definition of woke was
supposed to be being alert to injustice
in society
but because the woke now see race first
and everything else never
fear of being accused of racism has
given a free pass on human rights abuses
to china and any other places that are
perceived as non-white if china was in
europe would they get away with having
concentration camps without more of an
outcry from america if men
were forcing women to wear this and say
massachusetts would that go as
unremarked on as it does
the chinese classified transgender as a
mental illness
they just edited friends episodes so
that ross's wife is definitely not a
lesbian
how would that go over here
didn't martha luther king say an
injustice anywhere is a threat to
justice everywhere
uh
can we can we still quote him
in in 2020 nba players wore jerseys that
said freedom speak up and justice
but i guess those things only matter for
home games
sorry weakers
someone has to tell me where we got this
rule that you can't criticize china
because i suspect we got it from china
because after all it's where we get
everything else
you